vous avez ici une minute à moi et me
poser toutes les questions je ne répond
que par oui ou par non au nom non pour
trouver qui est le nouveau chroniqueur
qui intègre l'équipe de tpm pays
question oui est-ce qu'il a joué dans
alerte à malibu pense à david hasselhoff
est ce qu'il est déjà venu comme invité
sur ce plateau oui est ce que c'est un
ancien animateur non estimé non le
connaît bien
oui et non humoriste non chanteurs non
est ce qui va plaire à mes copines
oui est-ce qu'il est français ou les
comics internationale dans un cas à
saint-louis matin soit de chez moi que
pensez
vous
s'il vous plaît être qu'il était
difficile à convaincre oui sur ma liste
est ce qu'il est ce qu est ce qui les
tunisiens n'ont produit est bon il vient
de la politique
légaux oui oh il ya eu 10 politique et
j'en viens de la droite non il croit
qu'il est passé par là de
[Rires]
marquer politiquement
oui et non est-ce-qu'il magie bien oui
d'origine maghrébine oui est ce que vous
l'avez reçu dans btp est ce qu'il est né
à maraka j'ai pas répondu mais tp ida
est ce qui les met à mal les chances à
qui jamel debbouze inachevé un père noël
mamère devons
jamais
un signe vestimentaire distinctif oui à
une écrevisse sur le cas de son corps ne
porte pas des sharp ah bon est-ce que ça
questionne barbie est ce que son prénom
on commence par un quart
regardez il arrivé
[Applaudissements]
à
schaerbeek mais comme je vois plus en
btp on va prendre btp bien sûr en
janvier car il voit là il va venir un
peu nous voir dans tp pour réagir avec
nous sur l'actualité et vous savez que
voilà c'est mon ami on adore mes
serveurs nationale vous avez
tous
les
cas merci karim d'éclat